hello everyone so here I'm going to talk
about the directional derivative and
that's a way to extend the idea of a
partial derivative and partial
derivatives if you'll remember have to
do with functions with some kind of
multi variable input and I'll just use
two inputs because that's the easiest to
think about and it could be some single
variable output it could also deal with
vector variable outputs we haven't
gotten to that yet so we'll just think
about a single variable ordinary real
number output that's you know an
expression of x and y and the partial
derivative one of the ways that I said
you could think about it is to take a
look at the input space your x and y
plane so this would be the x axis this
is y and you know vaguely in your mind
you're thinking that somehow this
outputs to a line this outputs to just
the real numbers and maybe you're
thinking about a transformation that
takes it there or maybe you're just
thinking okay this is the input space
that's the output and when you take the
partial derivative at some kind of point
so I'll write it out like partial
derivative of F with respect to X at a
point like 1/2 you think about that
point you know 1 Y is equal to 2 and if
you're taking with respect to X you
think about just nudging it a little bit
in that X direction and you see what the
resulting nudge is in the output space
and the ratio between the size of that
resulting nudge and the original one the
ratio between you know partial F and
partial X is the value that you want and
when you did it with respect to Y you
know you were thinking about traveling
in a different direction maybe you you
nudge it straight up and you're
wondering okay how does that influence
the output and the question here with
directional derivatives what if you have
some vector V I'll give a little vector
hat on top of it that you know I don't
know let's say it's negative 1/2 is the
vector so you'd be thinking about that
as a step of negative 1 in the X
direction and then 2 more in the Y
direction so it's going to be something
that ends up there this is your vector V
at least if you're thinking of V is
stemming from the original point and
you're wondering what does it nudge in
that direction due to the function
itself and remember with these original
you know nudges in the X Direction
nudges in the Y you're not really
thinking of it is you know this is kind
of a large step you're really thinking
of it is something eating any bitty bit
of a tea you know it's not that but it's
really something very very small and
formally you'd be thinking about
limit as this gets really really really
small approaching zero and this gets
really really small approaching zero
what does the ratio of the two approach
and similarly with the Y you're not
thinking of it is something this is this
is pretty sizable but it would be
something really really small and the
directional derivative is similar you're
not thinking of the actual vector
actually taking a step along that but be
thinking of taking a step along say H
multiplied by that vector and H might
represent some really really small
numbers I know maybe this here is like
0.001 and when you're doing this formula
you just be thinking the limit as H goes
to zero so the directional derivative is
saying when you take a slight nudge in
the direction of that vector what is the
resulting change to the output and one
way to think about this is you say well
that's slight nudge of the vector if we
actually expand things out and we look
at the definition itself it'll be
negative H negative one times that
component and then to H here so it's
kind of like you took negative one nudge
in the X direction and then two nudges
in the Y direction you know so for
whatever your whatever your nudge in the
V Direction there you take a negative
one step by X and then 2 of them up by Y
so when we actually write this out the
notation by the way is you take that
same nabla from the gradient but then
you put the vector down here so this is
the directional derivative in the
direction of V and there's a whole bunch
of other notations too you know I think
there's like derivative of F with
respect to that vector is one way people
think about it some people will just
write like partial with a little
subscript vector there's a whole bunch
of different notations but this is the
one I like you think that nabla with a
little little F down there with a little
V for your vector of F and it's still a
function of x and y and the reason I
like this is it's indicative of how you
end up calculating it which I'll talk
about at the end of the video and for
this particular example a good guess
that you might have is to say well we
take a negative step in the X direction
so you think of it as whatever the
change that's caused by such a step in
the X Direction you do the negative of
that and then it's two steps in the Y
direction
so whatever the change caused by a tiny
step in the Y direction let's just take
two of those
two times partial F partial Y and this
is actually this is Iraq is actually how
you calculate it and if I was going to
be more general
you know let's say we've got a vector W
I'm going to keep it abstract and just
call it a and B as its components other
than the specific numbers you would say
that the directional derivative in the
direction of W whatever that is of F is
equal to a times the partial derivative
of F with respect to X plus B times the
partial derivative of F with respect to
Y and this is it this is the formula
that you would use for the directional
derivative and again the way that you're
thinking about this is you're really
saying you know you take a little nudge
that's a in the X direction and B in the
Y direction so this should kind of make
sense and sometimes you see this written
not with respect to the partial
derivatives themselves and the actual
components a and B but with the with
respect to the gradient and this is
because it makes it much more compact
more general if you're dealing with
other dimensions so I'll just write it
over here if you look at this expression
it looks like a dot product if you take
the dot product of the vectors a B and
the one that has the partial derivatives
in it so what's lined up with a is the
partial derivative with respect to X
partial F partial X and what's lined up
with B is the partial derivative with
respect to Y and you look at this and
you say hey a B I mean that's that's
just the original vector right that's W
that's the vector W and then your
dotting this with well partial
derivative with respect to X and one
component the other partial derivative
and the other component that's the dirt
that's just the gradient that is the
gradient of F and here you know it's
nabla without that little that little W
at the bottom and this is why we use
this notation because it's so suggestive
of the way that you ultimately calculate
it so this is this is really what you'll
see in a textbook or C as the compact
way of writing it and you can see how
this is more flexible for dimensions so
if we were talking about something that
has like a five dimensional input
the vector the direction you move has
five different components this is
flexible when you expand that the
gradient would have five components and
the vector itself would have five
components so this is the directional
derivative and how you calculate it and
the way you interpret you're thinking of
moving moving along that vector by a
tiny nudge by a tiny you know little
value multiplied by that vector and
saying how does that change the output
and what's the ratio of the resulting
change and in the next video I'll
clarify that with the formal definition
of the directional derivative itself